junge menschen in der pandemie viele
schüler und studierende fordern ein
schnelles impfangebot niederlande unter
schock wer steckt hinter dem
mordanschlag auf den
enthüllungsjournalisten peter de vries
möge der beste gewinnen fans aus england
und dänemark hoffen auf ein em finale
gegen italien
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sprinter für den
gesundheitsminister ist die sache klar
entweder man werde gegen korona geimpft
oder man werde infiziert jens spahn
fordert einen nationalen impfung um das
tempo hoch zu halten und eine hohe
impfquote zu erreichen damit die zahlen
im herbst nicht wieder nach oben gehen
denn der anteil der hoch ansteckenden
delta variante an den neuinfektionen
steigt und liegt nun bei mindestens 59
prozent so neueste zahlen des erkannten
dabei stecken sich vor allem junge
menschen an die ja meist ungeimpft sind
zuletzt betrug die sieben tage inzidenz
im schnitt 5 bei den 15 bis 24 jährigen
laxey doppel zu hoch viele schüler und
studenten drängen auf ein schnelleres
impfangebot christoph distel impftermin
an der hochschule koblenz luisa ist
studentin jung gesund über den normalen
im weg wäre sie vielleicht nicht so
schnell dran
diese sonderaktion quasi eine abkürzung
angst vor delta hat looser nicht macht
aber mit weil ich also ich bin halt
studentin und irgendwie sozialer kontakt
ganz nett und 30.000 dosen stellt
rheinland pfalz mehreren hochschulen zur
verfügung um die impfkampagne
voranzubringen resonanz zum auftakt
durchwachsen in koblenz hätten sich
sieben mal so viele anmelden können
trotzdem hoffen die verantwortlichen
auch dank solcher aktionen darauf dass
wir eine generation von studierenden
wieder in die lage versetzen miteinander
untereinander zu reden und gemeinsam zu
lernen auch für die schüler entscheidet
sich jetzt wie es nach den ferien weiter
geht
ihre vertreter fordern daher zumindest
ein angebot für alle ab 12 noch in den
sommerferien und da so früh wie möglich
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt in
eben am anfang der ferien die erste
impfung als angebot erhalten und eben am
ende die zweite dann können wir
sozusagen einen immunschutz staates
gewährleisten
ein extra programm für schüler im sommer
also der gesundheitsminister will sich
da nicht festlegen weil es die
impfkommission für diese altersgruppe ja
auch nicht tut gleichzeitig bewirkt er
massiv um die eigeninitiative der jungen
ich finde wir sollten einfach die kinder
und jugendlichen selbst entscheiden
lassen um mehr für sich das möchte dem
machen wir das möglich auch bis
spätestens ende august die erste impfung
und dann auch bald die zweite impfung zu
bekommen schüler ab 12 und studenten
zusammen genommen das sind in
deutschland immerhin fast neun prozent
der gesamtbevölkerung die spannende
frage also reichen die impf anreize der
einen und die bereitschaft der anderen
damit das land sicher in den herbst
gehen kann
mindestens 30 millionen corona impfdosen
will deutschland bis ende des jahres an
entwicklungsländer und andere staaten
abgeben
für die kostenlosen spenden sollen
impfdosen der hersteller astrazeneca und
johnson johnson genutzt werden
das geht aus einem bericht des
gesundheitsministeriums hervor der im
kabinett vorgelegt wurde
die korona zahlen sind leicht gestiegen
das robert koch institut meldet 985
fälle innerhalb eines tages 177 mehr als
vergangenen mittwoch 48 todesfälle kamen
binnen 24 stunden hinzu diese zahlen
dokumentieren allerdings nur einen teil
der wahrheit denn 40 prozent der
infektionen tauchen offenbar in der
statistik gar nicht auf weil die leute
gar nicht merken dass sie infiziert sind
das ist ein ergebnis einer groß
angelegten studie aus mainz darin
betonen die wissenschaftler auch wie
wichtig das testen bleibt selbst für
komplett geimpfte bobic area mehr als
10.000 menschen wurden an der
universitätsmedizin mainz seit oktober
2020 mehrfach befragt und untersucht
das ziel der guttenberg co wird 19
studie erkenntnisse über die
medizinischen und gesellschaftlichen
auswirkungen der pandemie zu gewinnen
ein ergebnis betrifft die korona
dunkelziffer durch mehrere tests konnte
bei 645 probanden eine akute oder
vergangene corona infektion nachgewiesen
werden
40 prozent von ihnen hätten ohne die
studie nichts von ihrer infektion
gewusst
die forscherinnen und forscher sind
überzeugt auch die bundesweite zahl der
infizierten muss höher liegen als
offiziell erfasst ist interessant war
für uns zu sehen dass das häufiger
männer sind die unwesentliche infiziert
sind und eher ältere menschen kinder
seien keine pandemie treiber so ein
weiteres ergebnis und menschen aus
sozial schwächeren schichten treffe die
pandemie besonders hart nicht nur
finanziell
sie seien besonders schutzbedürftig und
müssten in der impfkampagne gezielt
angesprochen werden
erstens bessere kommunikation
kommunikation über die risiken aber auch
die chancen zweitens alt abbau von
barrieren das heißt also möglichst auch
am arbeitsplatz impfen in situationen in
denen menschen geimpft werden die
beispielsweise kein hausarzt haben die
studie habe zudem gezeigt dass in den
vergangenen wochen weniger getestet
wurde
besonders bei vollständig geimpften und
genießen den menschen eine gefährliche
entwicklung so die forscher
denn auch geimpfte und genießen könnten
das virus immer noch übertragen
nach den ersten ergebnissen von heute
wollen die mainzer forscher weitere
informationen aus dem umfangreichen
datenmaterial herausfiltern
wenn sie fragen haben zu dieser studie
bei zdf heute live ist einer der autoren
zu gast um 19 uhr 30 zu sehen auf zdf
heute in der app und den social media
kanälen in den niederlanden bangen die
menschen um einen der prominentesten
journalisten des landes peter de vries
wurde gestern abend von mehreren kugeln
in den kopf getroffen mitten in
amsterdam
der 64 jährige gilt als experte auf dem
gebiet der organisierten kriminalität
zwei verdächtige wurden festgenommen
gunnar krüger berichtet
halte durch peter kaempfe
genesungswünsche mitten im ausgehviertel
gestern abend liegt hier ein mann auf
dem pflaster
er kommt mit schusswunde am kopf in die
mittlerweile stark bewachte notaufnahme
in diesem moment wissen wir er ist
schwer verletzt er kämpft um sein leben
der mann ist peter r de vries
niederländern bekannt als
enthüllungsjournalist und als
medienberater für opfer von verbrechen
und angst vor
das ist ein anschlag auf einen mutigen
journalisten und damit ein anschlag auf
die freie presse ein anspruch der frage
schon mal das stück de vries wollte
keinen polizeischutz er berät aber
derzeit im größten drogenprozess der
niederlande den kronzeugen sich um die
höre ich jetzt aus sorge um meine
sicherheit greifen dann könnte ich nicht
mehr in den spiegel schaut nicht mehr
schocken und gehrke als er den auftrag
übernahm waren ein bruder des zeugen und
ein anwalt schon ermordet nach den
jüngsten schüssen gibt es nun zwei
festnahmen aber auch kritik der
amsterdamer die polizei sei zu schwach
gegen die mafia die politik lenkt ab mit
der sorge um die freie presse club darum
geht es jedoch gar nicht es geht und
kriminalität und wie mächtig die drucker
vier geworden ist rückläufig
tatsächlich klagt auch die gewerkschaft
die niederländische regierung sagt oft
das geht nicht das darf nicht sein das
ist nicht hinnehmbar
aber wenn wir da nur investitionen in
die sicherheit bieten und so was zu
verhindern dann passiert nichts oder
wenig nichts stört weil das vertrauen in
den rechtsstaat die schüsse von
amsterdam könnten es tief erschüttern
sachsen-anhalt steuert auf eine
politische premiere zu die deutschland
koalition cdu spd und fdp wollen über
ein regierungsbündnis verhandeln
gut drei wochen wurde sondiert jetzt
sind sich alle drei parteien sicher in
wesentlichen punkten habe man eine basis
die spitzengremien müssen den
koalitionsverhandlungen noch zustimmen
läuft alles wie geplant
wäre die bisherige kenia koalition
geschichte und die grünen damit raus
seit der wiedervereinigung 1990 haben
sich ost und west angeglichen dennoch
gibt es weiterhin charakteristische
unterschiede heißt es im jahresbericht
der bundesregierung zum stand der
deutschen einheit im osten gebe es eine
skeptischere distanzierte und auch
kritischere grundeinstellung gegenüber
politik und demokratie bei der
wirtschaftsleistung hin der osten weiter
hinterher das bruttoinlandsprodukt
erreichte 2020 rund 78 prozent des
westdeutschen niveaus 2010 waren es
allerdings noch knapp 70 der abstand
wird also kleiner stefan kech über zwei
ostdeutsche erfolgsgeschichten
früher stellte das schweizer unternehmen
meyer burger produktionsanlagen für
solarmodule her und exportierte das know
how weltweit bis die konkurrenz ist
billiger konnte jetzt produziert meyer
burger solarpaneele selbst in freiberg
in sachsen
zwölf jahre lang entwickelten sie eine
neue technologie für solarzellen die
deutlich effektiver sein sollen als die
der konkurrenz
millionen hat das unternehmen investiert
doch das eigentliche kapital seien die
hiesigen arbeitskräfte sofern es noch
welche auf dem arbeitsmarkt gibt es gibt
glaube ich nur noch wenige regionen in
deutschland oder auch ostdeutschland die
irgendwie unter einem arbeitslosigkeit
problem leiden also hat arbeitsmarkt
seit ich niemand auf mainburger gewartet
in den sächsischen ballungsräumen
konkurrieren inzwischen viele
unternehmen um gut qualifizierte
arbeitskräfte sachsen hat ja eine ganze
reihe vorteile vor allem fern drei
großstädte und ein umfeld von
hochschulen von forschungseinrichtungen
und dass es gerade für
technologieorientierte unternehmen eben
sehr attraktiv sich dort anzusiedeln
aus einer dieser hochschulen der uni
chemnitz kommt der chef des vormals
kleinen startups bei 24 der bislang nur
insidern bekannte online händler für
fahrer teilemarkt inzwischen dem sprung
an die börse
wir haben letztes jahr knapp 200
millionen euro umsatz gemacht und haben
knapp 1,5 millionen pakete weltweit
verschickt wir verschicken 80 länder
aber der hauptfokus ist europa deshalb
will bei 24 expandieren das geld dafür
100 millionen sammelte das ostdeutsche
unternehmen an der börse mit
leichtigkeit eigen nach vw jetzt daimler
der verbraucherzentrale bundesverband
will schadenersatz für mercedes fahrer
erstreiten die vom diesel skandal
betroffen sind und dafür eine
musterklage vor dem oberlandesgericht
stuttgart gegen daimler eingereicht der
vorwurf lautet manipulation der
abgaswerte bei bestimmten modellen
daimler hält die ansprüche für
unbegründet vor rund sieben jahren
hatten bilder aus einer notunterkunft
für geflüchtete in burbach in nordrhein
westfalen für aufsehen gesorgt über
monate waren dort bewohner eingesperrt
gequält und geschlagen worden
heute nun das urteil gegen weitere vier
angeklagte vor dem landgericht siegen
die drei mitarbeiter eines wachdienstes
und ein betreuer müssen wegen
freiheitsberaubung eine geldstrafe
zwischen 900 und 3500 euro zahlen
strafmildernd wirkte sich unter anderem
die fehlende ausbildung der angeklagten
aus sagte das gericht in haiti ist der
präsident des landes sowie luise in
seinem haus erschossen worden
der 53-jährige hatte das bitterarme land
zuletzt verlass regiert die 2019
geplante parlamentswahl war unter
anderem wegen protesten gegen ihn
verschoben worden
louis werden korruption und verbindungen
zur gewalttätigen banden vorgeworfen
die eu zeigte sich schockiert von dem
mord und fürchtet weitere gewalt und
jetzt schauen wir in die stadt in der
korona so heftig wütete wie sonst kaum
auf der welt nach new york zur hoch-zeit
der pandemie im april des vergangenen
jahres starben dort mehr als 1000
menschen täglich in kühllaster stapelten
sich die leichen heute feiert new york
das ende der pandemie und bedankt sich
mit einer parade bei all den
welchen helfer johannes hano brütende
hitze schon um 11 uhr morgens new yorker
canyon of heroes der häuserschlucht am
broadway in der amerika seine helden
herd new york sei im vergangenen jahr
durch die größte krise seiner geschichte
gegangen hatte der bürgermeister gesagt
heute werden die geehrt die die stadt
und das ganze land durch ihren einsatz
vor dem untergang bewahrt haben
krankenhauspersonal transport
arbeiterinnen rettungskräfte für uns ist
das das licht am ende des tunnels es ist
zeit glücklich zu sein
es ist ganz wichtig für die moral das
war ein sehr langes hartes sie konfetti
paraden sind in new york die ihnen
vorbehalten
für die stadt und amerika herausragendes
geleistet haben siegreichen general
eisenhower oder metapher aus dem all
heimgekehrten astronauten oder zuletzt
der us fußball frauen nationalmannschaft
nach ihren weltmeistertitel
angeführt wird die parade heute von
central in see
die krankenschwester aus new york hatte
die erste impfung in den usa bekommen
und wurde für ihren einsatz gerade erst
von us-präsident beiden ausgezeichnet
viele gewerkschaften aber haben dazu
aufgerufen die parade zu boykottieren
mit ihrer alleine könnte man seine miete
nicht bezahlen eine ordentliche
bezahlung wäre die angemessene
respektbekundung mit der parade werden
aber auch die geehrt die im kampf gegen
das virus ihr leben gelassen haben
allein rund 4000 krankenschwestern
pfleger und ärzte sind in den usa
bislang an cupid gestorben jetzt zur
fußball-em norbert nach dem halbfinale
gestern ist vor dem finale heute
und vielleicht gibt es ja noch mal so
ein nervenkrimi wie italien gegen
spanien gestern abend spitzenfußball
zwei mannschaften auf augenhöhe und die
entscheidung erst im elfmeterschießen
italien schaffte den finaleinzug die
fans total aus dem häuschen in ganz
europa
ob hier in köln in rom oder london die
italiener sind im spielfieber giorgio
gebürtiger brasilianer schießt sie ganz
cool ins finale
dieser weg ist noch nicht zu ende wir
müssen jetzt regenerieren für das große
finale
das herrliche 10 der azzurri durch
chiesa beantwortet morata mit dem eins
zu eins für spanien aber dem gerade noch
glücklichen torschützen versagen im
elfmeterschießen die nerven und danach
beginnt la festa italiana und heute
abend das zweite halbfinale live bei uns
im zdf ab 20 15 england gegen dänemark
die briten favorisiert hoch motiviert
und mit dem zwölften mann im
wembley-stadion die 60.000 zuschauer in
wembley dem englischen fußball tempel
wird es heute wieder emotional das
heimische team soll großes schaffen den
ersten endspiel einzug seit der wm 1966
wieder die unterstützung im ganzen land
ist riesig das ist schon ein tolles
gefühl und wir sind bereit für das spiel
zumal der kapitän wieder trifft harry
caine zuletzt gegen die ukraine sogar
doppelt doch auch die dänen konnten im
viertelfinale gegen tschechien
überzeugen so das spiel hat uns den
glauben daran gegeben dass wir auch
jetzt gewinnen auf jeden fall trägt
wembley heute rot weiß die farben beider
nationen und gewinnen könnte das
hungrige retina béla réthy kommentiert
das spiel heute abend bei uns im zdf
weder was erwartest du was erwartet die
zuschauer uns mal aufzugreifen der
hunger der engländer ist natürlich
gewaltig nach 55 jahren können sie
wieder mal ein endspiel erreichen und
der magen ist besonders leer aber der
appetit dem den sollte man nicht
unterschätzen also die sind zwar
außenseiter aber diese märchenhafte
reise geht hier natürlich weiter und
dadurch das drama um ihren kapitän
christian eriksen ist die mannschaft
noch weiter zusammengerückt sportlich
ist england favorisiert aber die
britischen fans werden ideen auch
würdigen und ich denke mal ihr herz auch
zeigen den kleinen dänemark ihr vor
60.000 in wembley
danke béla réthy
von london nach münchen da war heute
trainingsauftakt bei den bayern mit dem
ersten auftritt von julia nagelsmann als
neuer fcb-coach der gleich eine wichtige
personalie verkündete torwart manuel
neuer soll kapitän bleiben der
bundesliga auftakt dann am dritten
august mit dem spiel gladbach gegen die
bayern und zur tour de france heute eine
ganz außergewöhnliche bergetappe in der
provence die der belgier laut fahrt
gewann erstmals in der geschichte der
tour musste der legendäre 1910 meter
hohe mont ventoux gleich zweimal an
einem tag bezwungen werden
laut van aart die vierte alle klasse und
siegte souverän
titelverteidiger teddy boccaccio im
gelben trikot wurde vierter und konnte
seinen vorsprung in der gesamtwertung
noch ausbauen
[Musik]
das war's vom sport danke schülern fehlt
noch das lotto die gewinnzahlen lauten
28 23 29 31 43 und die superzahl 9
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auch im
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5
157 wenig veränderung gibt es beim
wetter morgen drohen erneut schwere
unwetter mit starkregen mehr dazu hat
gleich aus den terry das heute journal
mit marietta slomka in der halbzeitpause
gegen viertel vor zehn hier begrüßt sie
morgen christian sievers einen
spannenden abend wünschen wir ihnen
alles gute und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend bevor wir aufs
wetter schauen ein kurzer blick auf die
juni klima karte über der antarktis war
es deutlich zu kalt und obwohl es da zu
kalt war war das global der vierte
ernste juni zusammen mit dem jahr 2018
denn auf der nordhalbkugel war es
deutlich zu warm zum beispiel über
sibirien oder über nordamerika aber auch
über europa und über europa war es der
zweitwärmste juni bisher
wir schauen auf die nacht und da kommen
schauer und gewitter aus dem südwesten
auf ansonsten ist es trocken bei
temperaturen von 11 grad im westen und
15 grad im osten 16 im südosten
deutschlands morgen tagesverlauf ist
eine menge los mit unwetter an heftigen
gewittern im süden und auch nach
nordwesten hin und diese gewitter
schwenken im tagesverlauf südostwärts
ansonsten ist es ganz im nordosten
trocken bei temperaturen bis 26 grad im
norden und 20 grad am alpenrand unwetter
gibt es noch am freitag vor allem im
osten deutschlands bei 26 grad am
samstag können die gewitter immer noch
unwetterartig sein temperaturen bis 28
grad damit ein schöner abend